Hello and welcome friends to Papers, Please
It's gaming week, epic fun time! Smash like for gaming week! Today we're playing Papers, Please
Jack told me this game gets views.
I like those
So we will play Papers, please
I, of course, have played this game before
So I know how to play game.
It's game about being border guard
How does this look?
♪ Ey congratulations to your corporation ♪
♪ I won a labor lottery and now I menstruation ♪
My name was pulled, excellent!
(Reading) For immediate placement report to the Minis- Ok, the Grestin border check-
THE GRESTIN BORDER CHECKPOINT
Whaaaat
That's the most dangerous checkpoint in all of Arstotzka
I will get apartment
For family
Ah, wow
すごい
Glory to Arstotzka
Glory
to...
the mother...
poopie.
What am I saying?
I don't know
November 23rd, now the rule is simple, of this game
(Reading) Inspector welcome to new position of Grestin border control. Okay. Stamp passport entry visa, uh-huh
Ok, deny all foreigner
I Spit on the foreigner, glory to Arstotzka!
Next
Papers
Finally I can return
Islakova Antonia
hmm
What a beautiful picture ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Approve- ah, wait, Arstotzka -  Approved!
Enjoooy, have good time. Arstotzka welcomes.
Neeext
Dasvidaniya, ok, Szaszko Eyan. Let's see...
Tsunkeido?!
GET OUT OF MY FAAACE
Arstotzkans only, don't waste my time
I have family to feed. Come on, how long am I going to do this accent? that is so bad?
I waited in this damn line for 8 hours. I hope it was worth it.
Well, too bad you ugly snake
You can't come, Arstotzkans only
Get out of my face. Unbelievable, you spit- I spit
Disgusting
What about you?
Nice receding hairline. Okay. Oh, what a picture
Denied! Bye- bye! Bye- bye! Have your documents ready
Next
Oh, papers?
It was a mistake
You waited 8 hours to tell me that?
Pathetic.
Papers, please. All right. It's an Arstotzkan passport. Okay. Alright
Mr. Orry Viet one. I mean who knows whatever you're a prude get out of my face. Enjoy it
Check out the punter
glorious
Okay, we have whamon alright
Okay, though
You waste my time woman
You not only waste my time you waste other people time
next
Be appears at its thoughts can approve enjoy enjoy your time
So the thing with this game is that it gets more and more difficult as you go
There's new requirements that will change and you're incentivized to get as many people pass as possible
But at the same time if you make a mistake
You'll pay the penalty
It's a really interesting game. It's a really surprisingly fun game if anyone came and pitched to me like hey
Hey, there's this game where you play as a border guard?
I would be like that sounds lame but it's actually a really fun now. Obviously the first stage is really easy
At least that's how I remember it. We really just deny all the foreigners
Well, you look amazing
And who I almost am yes, oopsie whole much made oopsie
At least don't get on me
How many we have 11 papers arrest Otsuka? Oh
You can go you can go hurry
glory to arstotzka
We got 12
Odinnadcat'
Odin, dva, dvenadcat'
Today we don't need we sleep so you manage your budget?
Based on I don't know. I don't remember November 24th is a new day new opportunities
Ok, all right, ok, ok
Checkpoint all passports information carefully for descriptions is deny any entrant with inconsistent information?
You see now we have to use my mind
user in spectrum or using the red button and your -
Ok, so we have to highlight what the problems are
Ok, ok glory to arstotzka
Inspector
Politics neeext NYX. Come on
Open for business papers
Krista
So now we have to lock is it expired?
No yet female
the
glory to arstotzka
Cause no trouble yet
You'll see here if you make a mistake ok where she was fine, let's see
Aunt
agrea
What are you doing? You spit in my face. This is expired. It has expired interrogation. I
cannot enter I
Just renew it
Too bad, you will never know this country next
Get the real passport give me the goddamn Priapus. Okay, 1980. Mm-hmm Mel
eggrgfb
grbrbrbrbb
idk whst i write hahaha
You don't look like man
With this this question. Sorry, ma'am. No discrimination. I
Just what is this question? What do you mean? I don't know
Okay, it's not expired or there okay
approved
enjoy
Paris not sky welcomes everyone
As long as you meet the requirements
Papers give it to me our maid Nicole. Okiya female akhiya
Okay, I care
She looks a very strange on the picture
Next I think I'm Way too slow here. I notice Peter. No. No what I do invalid issuing country
Safety, hello handsome. You look bored if you want a good time
Yeah for gamers
Okay, thank you so para disma
What would what did oh god. I don't I can't believe I messed up
Unbelievable. It's part of the game, I guess
You're approved you can go
I'll be around a couple months. Don't forget to visit
Listen I can barely afford food, please. Oh nice scarf sir, is is there map?
What happened oh god someone's trying to run LLL shoot
Alright so here we go. This is the problem I did. Oh my god
Alright, so the problem is Kreskin is easy
Okay, we did it that was a good day I think that was very good in taste productive
Okay, good, yeah we need medicine her son, I don't think
We have to save money I don't have time for medicine for children, okay?
Verify information. Yeah. Yeah missing documents
Mm-hmm
Rule book
Okay, okay, let's check the rulebook really great because so we had C these are the only districts allowed in this area
So if we're real trihard, we'll check all the issuing countries. I think we have to do that
Okay open
Reappears, I guess at the end I will so this is a
bristan lawrence mail
Okay, you can go
What tell us this all they need an entry ticket as well I
Didn't even read that
Next oh they need about all foreigners need a ninja's again
Okay, well clearly
What do you mean no correlation
How do I ask her about the ant
How do I ask about the entry ticket
Okay, she has an entry ticket it's valid from 1980 to 11. Okay, that's today god dammit stop giving me stuff
Okay, I'm too slow. I'm too slow. I know okay. God I female I don't expiry
You can go
Come to pink I don't ask for other
please
next
I'm too slow next please
my son
Will die. Okay. Well it starts cat doesn't need
Parodies nah
Dah
Welcome
Come on come on don't waste my time
Looking, uh, huh terrorist attack, you lucky have jobs. It was not my fault
Take
Restarts Cape welcome everyone. We have good time here. Very nice. Oh, very nice
República
One moment, right
This is wrong entry valid on deny deny
It add my prayer she tried to waste my time
Mer Galerius male, okay all looks good. It all looks good entry welcome
Next
Come on we need ten at least
Glory to arstotzka the greatest country in the world. All the countries are give me the king ding
Hello
To proceed use inspector mode to interrogate
Review page 2 of today's bulletin
There we go, oh
I see
Eddy Scott's got so great passport not required, right? Okay. Okay I come back again
Yeah, oh my god I wasted so much time
Well she from collegia whether that's correct
Female, you have to check yet. Very good
glory to arstotzka
The greatest country in the world
Give me the goddamn papers. Alright first, let's check this. It's valid gray
Yarko City. I remember your Co City
I'm very nice during winter
Can hardly feel my toes?
Your your Co City what what ha ha your acoustic day
What is your Co City your passport fault information? I will shoot you. I do not understand you don't understand
Well understand this I do I Spit on you and your mother
Bye-bye. No one will get past
The greatest border guard of all time through p2p, my son is sick. Oh
My study see yet, we don't have time to be sick
My son useless does my son parent yet my son
Wait, I didn't read they must show an ID card foreigners must secure an entry parent ok
Entry tickets are no longer service. They need an entry permit
Duration of stay ok. Ok
Ok, so enter must have a passport they must have current must have an ID card
Citizens must have antique are foreigners requiring entry permits. So this is the entry permit
so we gotta cross examine these two and
Enter by well, what the fuck is this?
Oh it matches all right, well I am stupid then oh
That's okay wait
You entered too early is that not a descriptions discrepancy
Why I
Got a bad feeling about this you're not denied your denied I
Don't like his face
Protocol violated, so even if you deny you can do it wrong. Alright, I guess they can enter by any fidon't
Three months
Scar there's so much to check now Olga Zara now, okay
Okay, visit three months I
Don't understand, um
Female, okay. The only thing I haven't checked this the city but I think it's correct. I remember Sookie neck. Oh
No trouble
Can't believe I got a warning this is the is awful
Give me the goddamn papers. No
Yeah, shut up
Okay, and
Three tickets
What is the permit
Oh my god nyet
Go back to your car. I
Don't care you paid use money for taking I don't care. I really don't care. Oh
My god, you're ugly. Oh
Okay, Diane all Diane oh
You think you can get me in there get these name don't match don't waste my you have two different
Oh, let's watch fingerprint. Give me this
Her name is a key Diane, Amna. Okay
It says you don't have two names
Why the names don't match my name changed recently
Is there a way to check that don't waste time go
Hey, hey, oh
I forgot
Hopefully I didn't do wrong I don't know I'm trying it's very hard very stressful yeah
That's the purpose of the trip I'm so happy that border opened I visit son I have not seen him six months, okay
Luke obscure Alexandre Luke obscure. Okay, enter, okay
Duration well
Yeah, now I got it I'm an idiot you it expired please let me pass my son waiting oh
My son waiting bye-bye. I'll tell your son. His mother is a cow
Okay, come on paper, please Alan Novick
Citizens Marika ID card, where oh there is this never mind
Okay, uh
my god
What is this why the name difference?
Why name different? I have two different name. Well, we'll be the double of check of that
Okay
Roar Nora
Yeah, yeah
Interrogate please let me through
Come back when you're not a bitch
Yes
This is fun
Come on come on papers what's purpose work? Okay to reaction
twelve weeks
Okay
Hi hun don't recognize. Hi, hon. What is high-end, huh?
Okay, hi I'm fine nineteen aha, okay
Okay work okay, hmm
Enjoy your time in glorious country Cosmo travel
Knee axe ah what I didn't belly name. No. No, it hurts. God, dammit
Pre-approved, okay. Okay. Let's play a lot
Where's entry permit is he gonna give us an entry permit?
And it starts get still best country for sure I
Like this guy one day you'll make it
Okay. Okay. You not like Passport. I understand I come back again with better water
And it starts k welcome papers, okay la Tosca again, okay la TomSka
Female
19. Oh, yeah. Okay. There's even the hi to look at and then wait there's so much to look at
They just require an ID card, right, I think that's fine
Laurie it starts again. Oh
My god what oh
God, I suck at this game. My son is gonna die now. My son is sick in head
My dirty dick shut up. I
Make mistake at work son. Don't get medicine. So what okay, I will try not to suck so bad this time. Okay
Glory to arstotzka
What what's the news you are now authorized to detain interrogate?
Description, please enable the tension the tension. I think it's this one, right?
Which one is the tension shouter counter
Okay next
Foreigners work ing permit citizen ID card one year. Okay. That's correct. Wait, what did she say work? Okay, that's correct
Passport what a lovely picture. Oh, yeah. Ah
Okay interrogation what is your problem
What why you waste my time
What do you mean check it again?
Hahahahaha
Oh the gulag
We send her to Siberia
And you will pay the crime of wasting my time at its thought sky glory to arstotzka
176 okay, so I am taller than crane. Yeah
Birthday okay grounded seaman appear 1983
Okay, okay looks good, right Alton district
Alton Alton I okay
I
Think I think you can enter yes, enjoy
Please don't mess up. God this give a stressful day. I
Think our what's the purpose?
Transit okay, how long?
Couple weeks. I
guess
Is that a description I'm being very picking it matching, okay?
Okay, let's check the name list rod Vince, okay, let's check the
Number okay. Okay. Okay. 1982. Okay Oh
Enter by now, I get I'm so stupid and
Less Brandi
This is a Republican, right? Yeah, let's less than Maddie. Okay. Okay. Okay everything good
have a great time and
smiles
great time and smiles
God I hope I don't mess up
Okay, nice hair
glory to arstotzka
Papers Samar and rock Samar and rock, okay
What is your problem you
Have two differently. Why does everyone have two different names? All right do this
In the meantime, I'll look at everything else. No known I'll
Know no Nile
What is your problem
What are you doing? Oh sorry, it's technical problem shoot him
Okay
Papers please. Don't waste time what's purpose of trade?
It's not my choice. I'm just duration of stay a
Little as possible you piece of shit
Fine, I have to do my job
Where is this from United Federation?
pathetic
Krista, okay
What's your name Nicholas Palermo, okay
1945 doesn't say
expire okiya
Okiya
Okay, what one second?
one second
What's the seal? Hmm?
What is this seal? Oh
Never mind fine
You may enter
God they like pink in these countries Sunday. What's the purpose transit? Okay duration
two weeks
dialog
ski-doo stone
Enter bye, okay
Okay
West Gradstein
Again I
Think it's so nerve-wracking. I
Really want to do a good job for my son. That will die
Papers come on papers. What's the purpose visit? Okay, how long?
Okay, 1934
Okay, okay
Yeah
Makayla lindahl that's gotta be reference is another developer Swedish and this is a Swedish name
Okay, let's check anti-gay, yeah
Okay, yeah, I
Think this is all fine
Yeah, of course. Welcome to beautiful country. All right, I think
They did a thing with a Kickstarter right that you could be a character in the game actually
I don't know if that's true. You look beautiful. Good day good day to you. Mr
roasted pewter
Finally become free
Again, I don't care what stock pewter
Okay
What was his reason
Emigrate. Okay forever good for you forever. Wow enter. Bye
Okay, is there a problem
Yet no problem sent Marie memo
What about if I can trying to find something to bust these guys on he's fine. You're fine. Enjoy
Please be kind to my wife. She's
Okay, hello Pierre purse did you see my
Where there where he is
Where is your entry permit
Where is it?
Don't waste my time get him I
Have to detain her I
Don't care you need entry permit
Don't waste my time you have doomed me bye-bye. I thought I could detain her. Oh
My son is sick, maybe he needs to grow up get some balls
Yeah jobs few becoming fewer what's a glorious day in Aries thoughts guy
I
Love my work
All right, the minutes later has instituted a special program to control immigrant labor
travelers entering for work require a valid work pass
Okay, how does that look like?
Documents work pants. Okay, so they need one of those seals
So entrance must have passport they must be current must have ID for this required entry permit
Workers must have a work. That's okay. Glorious day artist Otsuka
Papers come on. What pass work? Okay duration ruler
Mr. Adam save Vika Torah, Adam. Say Vika Torah
Okay, okay. Okay, okay
This is fine
In the work permit it's okay, right?
What is this, oh it is, correct
He's from república nyet he's from import
Da hai ban hai okay. Hi Nagesh image show show engaged
Sports
Yokas, Oh Adam a
Car there's so many things to look at now
Have your documents ready? Come on paper. This place was purpose plan to work
duration
six months da Oh
Yet
Not interested Michaela John of 'no I okay
Does it have the seal? Okay seal?
What is this place integrity? Yeah, what is this place a barista skull okay
Expire okay
Wet wet
Where is your entry permit others, okay
all nighter
Okay, okay, okay
Very good. Enjoy our city
good times
Please help me. What is this a
Name dari olodum promised me and my sister good work. I do not trust him
I'm afraid he will take away my passport. First me to work brother. Please - son I don't have time. This is not my job
Immigrating forever vicar Sam Alexander
Alexander bickerson Vickers. Ham Vickers ham. What a stupid name. You look mercury's
What country is this
Republican yet aunt agree yet
nyet nyet nyet nyet nyet o
Briston da
But what is marry Gary yes, what is this
The city is incorrect. I have no idea detained detain them take them away next
L don't white matter
Welcome glory to arstotzka what is purpose transit? Okay
Couple days. Okay Rubina, Svetlana. Hmm. Okay. Oh
Okay, okay
Not every day I approve someone
No
Invalid expiration they goddamn it. Why didn't you not tell me?
God this you again. This looks good
But I'm sorry you need
You need entry permit
I'm sorry. He actually has a good one for one. Oh man, you funny guy
Now I need the entry permit
Why you're on very strict border that this good job job, right I looked everything and come back
The patience of this guy, I love it one day one day he'll make it through papers, please. Oh my god
Where's the passport
They took away my passport he hasn't temporary visa. Oh
So it's just to deny him interesting
That is thoughts can
Foreigners recording it citizens ID card. Okay God you keep giving me this stuff
Ludum daddy
And what is suspicious photo?
1946 their rate n is 179
No, okay. I'm fine. 81-kilo. Okay, and
You expire?
We don't have a problem unless unless I
Need to learn like you save so much time it wins once you learn the city's glory to arstotzka
lori its kasta
Whenever I have proved someone I feel like ah like that yeah Paris because when you deny, you know for sure you better right?
Okay, we know that's right now we remember that
So if they are heavier than normal it means they're carrying contraband so we get to inspect them later, I remember it
Baya, this looks fine
No
What is this the date don't match I've no idea what you're talking about detain detain
Sender to Siberia
Next
glory to arstotzka
Papers work pass, okay
Duration twelve weeks, okay
Okay, oh
Sorry fuck where's his passport?
Okay, there's so much to look at now God your Co City, I think that's correct
Your Co City da
Mail okay. Sure Luckman
Lockman Stefan Lachman health care. Okay, it's Stefan. I think I think everything is so
Okay. No. No, that's fine. That's fine
Lucky you
You get a proven?
Have a great time. Oh
He made it okay papers, why does he look so weird
You will visit friends 60 days
Why I don't press that what happened no
Goddamn it
Your son is sick and needs medicine
Move upgrade press space to toggle inspect mode
Well, I need I need I can't afford I guess I'll get heating
Glorious day I love my one. Yeah. Okay. Let's check out the inspect book
Search all before approving their entry because of the bombing yesterday. Ok
Glorious day no. Yeah, ok. So now we can respect them. Ok
This goddamn City
Couple months sciency what she said visiting that's correct
Enter bye. Ok, ok
Alberta demacia Damacio ok missing ok
So
Rolls, the rules. He said all collections must be searched. I'm pressing space. How do I search?
You we selected you for a random search a random search totally random turn towards scanner
I think this is now we get to see some
Filthy colleague here. Ah
Lavinia
Well, you are fined up. You should not see this. I save this
Welcome to collect yeah
I mean arstotzka
Neeext
haha
Papers kaliesha, we have selected you visit
We have selected you for a random search
That's crazy we never do this
Random completely random
Evade or expire
Yeah
I will not save this
Okay, very well. You are a proof
glory to arstotzka I
Think we're doing pretty good papers, please goddamn collections we have selected you
Two weeks, okay, this is crazy. You will never do this. I swear completely random
Jacquelyn Colonel weather I remember bed or
Oh
But will not save this
Expiry enter by Colonel Jacqueline. Okay glory to arstotzka
I
Want to deny someone come on stop being good
Papers come on. My glorious arrest was
Submitted to Kayla one on this industry, okay
Okay
Switzer camera, hmm, okay
Or avec runner
It's all okay, I think
Burnt on district
Like I did something wrong here, I'm just gonna try and speed it up
Invalid gender what the hell was that then?
I should have checked stupid. It's the only thing I didn't check. Where's your fucking passport now? I'm getting pissed off
You don't have it Oh valina damn Pope's Chaya
Nineteen enter by
Female fine got a check though. God damages are so many things to check
The United Federation
Christa da
These correct da
Transit
Couple days this one is fine. This one for sure is fine
The real question is who checks the checker, right?
Yeppers, this is crazy. We never do this
Huh, okay Olga - Shin skaia transit
But what is this
Detention
Okay, there we go no weapons, what are you doing you made the mistake good saying
What is wrong with people
Nice mustache, this is crazy. This is crazy. We never do this. I've never seen this in my job
The ratio to stay a couple of weeks visiting friends visit ok
Very tiny peepee. Very tiny
Filthy small peepee collections no weapons
Goddammit it's in the way
What are you doing you made a mistake Nani slow down my friend
I'll give you ten credits. You cannot bribe an officer of various thoughts. Can they must be?
Neeext
Papers
Purpose transit couple weeks
Okay, ba ba ba ba ba ba teshia
Jen rush
texia generation
female Loren dress
What is Loren dress I don't recognize why do I not recognize fuck I forgot which one are any
Lauren does okay fine
Expire 1984. I think she's okay enter by 19
Yep. Okay, fine. Enjoy
It's so much scarier to approve. Okay, this is the last one trains it
Time to
14-day transit correct enter by correct
Correct, correct
Beautiful men I want to let him through
This is no yet God, why does it go back all the way?
Hi, hon
we might as well not if there's a
male
expire I
Think this one is okay
Welcome to glorious country. My son is dying
So that is our first day in glorious era starts can son is sick
Boo-hoo-hoo. I
Don't care
Why should I care?
We're running really low on everything
My
everyone's hungry
My hunk. Oh, this is great
Thank you for watching this episode of gaming week. Very epic and very nice smash like for gaming
We buy all the merch and I see you tomorrow glory to arstotzka
What you never played to simulator?
You know, it's fun right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price